lorsque j'ai appris que mon invité
d'aujourd'hui a accepté de venir sur le
plateau de scoop à la une
j'ai été très très heureux pour la bonne
raison que ça fait à peu près vingt ans
que j'avais envie de la rencontrer
quand j'avais 16 ans que j'allais au
lycée et que je rentrais du lycée elle
m'attendait dans le transistor sur le
frigo dans la cuisine et elle était avec
les beatles et les suprêmes salut les
copains
bien sûr depuis on s'est un peu perdu de
vue
elle a fait sa vie elle a même refait
récemment elle est devenue une grande
star n'en achètent pas j'étais sûr qu'un
jour ou l'autre je la rencontrerai
j'étais sûr que ça arriverait comme je
suis sûr que ça vous fait à tous très
plaisir aujourd'hui d'accueillir sylvie
vartan
merci bien alors sylvie j'ai retrouvé le
salut les copains de dia 20 ans à
l'époque
alors on va pas traîner à l'époque
c'étaient eux qui posait les questions
maintenant c'est moi mais je vais poser
les mêmes bons c'est une bonne idée ça
c'est une excellente idée
dès que j'aurai trouvé la page alors
sylvie quelle fut ma meilleure journée
d'année 1963 alors à l'époque tu disais
le lendemain de ma première à l'olympia
presque toutes les critiques des
journaux m'était favorable
alors aujourd'hui je te demanderai
quelle fut ma meilleure journée de
l'année 1960 85 1985 alors on joue je me
je pense un petit peu je pense que
c'était quand j'ai finalement terminé
mon album pourtant j'ai commencé il ya
un an
et j'avoue que
au fil des mois on cherchait des
chansons c'était un travail assez long
et quand on a terminé on était très
contents que moi c'est ça très bien
merci
alors quelles furent les plus mauvais
moment de cette année alors à l'époque
je vais 10e où je devais monter en scène
avec 40° de fièvre une angine et une
crise de foi c'était affreux
alors est ce que l'on se souvienne pas
est ce que cette année vous avez eu
l'occasion de monter sur scène avec non
je n'ai pas fait de l'année donc j'ai
fait beaucoup d'avions et ça ce n'est
jamais très agréable
donc c'est l'avion le plus mauvais
souvenir cette année c'est l'avion quel
film récente a le plus enthousiasmé
disait salut les copains et vous
répondiez à l'époque les side story
alors cette année quel est le film en 85
qui vous a le plus enthousiasmé
il y avait beaucoup de bons films
amadeus peut-être amadeus ouest une
bonne réponse merci
quelle voiture te paraît la plus belle à
l'époque c'était la ferrari ah oui je
dirai aussi la ferrari de l'affairé ont
changé d'avis et oui ça ça ne change pas
quelle est ta fleur préférée alors à
l'époque c'était une fleur des champs le
bleu et c'est mignon c'est très mignon
sérieux de plus mignon non mais je
tirais les gardénia une fille doit-elle
lorsqu'elles se marient avoir déjà eu ou
ne pas avoir eu d'expérience avec les
garçons à l'écran est très très bien
alors à l'époque cela dépend de ce qu'on
entend par expérience s'il s'agit pour
elle d'un amusement ou d'un passe temps
je ne la comprends pas si elle agit par
amour elle n'est pas condamnable mais en
cette matière de toute façon plus qu'en
tout autre
chacun et chacune doit trouver sa propre
solution il n'y a pas de règle générale
alors je répète est ce qu'une fille doit
ou non des relations sexuelles avec un
garçon avant son mariage ma chère sylvie
et bien je dirais oui
ah ben voilà les moeurs ont évolué merci
beaucoup d'avoir accepté de répondre à
cette interview de salut les copains